cent trente masques transparent
distribués par la ville d'elancourt pour
le personnel de ces crèches et la classe
réservée aux enfants autistes
un investissement nécessaire pour la
municipalité la commune souhaite
vraiment accompagner au mieux les
familles et puis permettre aux enfants
le meilleur du développement possible
on sait très bien que l'effet miroir est
très important c'est un enfant sur tous
les petits enfants et de l'ue les
stimulations que qui se passe
les enfants effectivement reproduit ce
qu'ils voient sur l'adulte et bien
souvent c'est comme ça que les enfants
commencent à vocaliser à la crèche du
petit prince on se réjouit de l'arrivée
2 et masque le personnel le porte
pendant les moments d'histoire ou de
continuer quand les enfants nous ont vus
avec ses masques pour la première fois
ils ont été surpris il voyait nos
bouches
donc c'était quelque chose de nouveau de
nous nouvelle nouveauté de pouvoir voir
nos bouches nos sourires ça fait quand
même partie de notre travail d'insister
sur les mimiques de nos expressions et
on a beau mettre tous dans le regard
la bouche le sourire tout ça ça nous
manquait mais les masses que transparent
ne sont pas porter tout au long de la
journée pour des raisons de confort on
les alternent avec les masques normaux
parce qu'il ya aussi des petites choses
qui nous dérange un petit peu dans ces
masques à les porter au quotidien
enfin sur tout âge on sait des masques
qui sont pas remplies xi place enfin une
matière un peu comme ça un peu presti
fiez donc comme un peu sur les lunettes
avec les max parce que les autres
la buée voilà donc un moment donné cette
buée s'installe et
soit là c'est pas c'est pas très
agréable un bilan donc positif pour les
professionnels les parents et surtout
les enfants
d'autres communes de l'agglomération se
sont également équipés en masques et
transparent
[Musique]